Memcached is a very fast in-memory cache. It was built
by a company called Danja, to power a website called
LiveJournal. And before Facebook took over the world, LiveJournal was
a very popular site where people had you know, their
own blogs. Kind of like Tumblr or Blogspot. I don't
know a bunch of, a bunch of things have, have
risen to take the, the place of LiveJournal. But LiveJournal
was a very popular site back in the day. And when
I say back in the day, I mean 2003 is when memcache was released. Now just
about every website on the internet uses memcache
these days. I don't know about Google but
certainly it's used by Facebook. It's used by
Reddit. You know, it's used by YouTube. Twitter,
it is an essential piece of software when
you're writing web applications. And in fact other than,
than Linux itself memcache is probably the piece of software
that's, most in common between every website online. It's, it's pretty
astounding. It's very, very simple. And it's very, very effective
at what it does. Okay. To draw a bigger version of
that picture I did on the quiz, how memcached fits
in, it looks something like this. Memcached is a process. Often
you run it on its own machine. But you can also
run it on the machines with your APP servers, and it's
a very simple system. The algorithm doesn't change. A request
comes in we check memcached. If a response is there, we
send it back to the user. If it isn't there
we check the database instead. And right to memcached, you know.
As we've been doing, the algorithm should be pretty familiar
to you by now. What's handy about it, is that all
of these apps servers can interact with memcached. Memcached is
fast enough and can support many, many sockets that it works
very well in this scenario. Also most memcached libraries have built
in towards this notion of having multiple memcached machines. Because memcached
is just a key value store. Just, it's like basically a
giant hash table. You can hash on the keys to decide which
server to send your data to. And because it's a cache
it's okay if you, you know, lose data from time to
time because you'll just get it, you'll get the authoritative copy
out of the database. And this distribution of keys over multiple servers
is gnereally handled by the library. You know, sometimes you have to
do it yourself. But most libraries and the Python library we'll be
using, and this class this abstracts all of this for you so
you don't have to deal with it. It's very common to actually
run a little memcache server on each machine, and then have each
app server you know, communicate to all the caches. You kind of get
this big ball of this big ball of connections. But everything works
out okay so. And mem cache is a very simple protocol and
the operations it does are very simple. So, ultimately we're going to
be storing you know keys to values. Where the keys and
values are both strings. And the operations look something like this.
We've got set and this takes a key and a value. And
we've got get, this takes a key and returns a value.
And we've got delete, which takes a key and deletes the key.
There are other operations and there are actually a few other
parameters here. But these are the basic ones, and you can see
what these three main operations, set, get, and delete, we could
actually implement all of the caching we've been doing in ASCIIchan
in a system that will scale a lot better than having,
you know, just a dictionary in our process. It also means
that if, the advantage you get from using memcaches if our
process restarts, we don't have an empty dictionary anymore, we have
our memcached and, and our content lives on. So, what I'd
like you to do first, is implement a fake version of memcached.